august 13th 1987. dear diary i went to
geno dolphin's birthday party this
weekend
we're not really that [ __ ] close
but he was up trying to pack in the
numbers to to get his present count up
[ __ ] worked
i got him castlevania
cam collins got him zelda too
[ __ ] ron rinaldi got him [ __ ]
contra that was a [ __ ] great game up
up down down left right left right ba
uh tammy timus got him punch out oh
remember that code
what was that code 007 373-59963
what is mike tyson what did that do get
you straight to mike tyson get the [ __ ]
out of here i didn't know that there was
a code to do that yeah dude really oh
yeah
i know that
rallio raleigh what is this rally oh
mcmurdy got a mega man mega man 2 is
better than mega man just saying sure
uh damn it timothy bubble got him
timothy bubble timothy bubble got him
[ __ ] double dragon
ameri
amanda le target
amanda la tarzay got him metal gear
sandy pendergrass
got him [ __ ] street fighter
race and [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] rachel cause face
rachel crustacean
got him shinobi
[ __ ] you know the goddamn
[ __ ] gibber pravallia got him
tecmo bowl [ __ ] jibber made it to the
party i'd do the same [ __ ] thing i'll
do the same [ __ ] thing for my
birthday party next year problem is
rachel crustacean rubs me the wrong
[ __ ] way
so i'd like to point out did you know a
racial rustic yes no this is exactly
what i wanted to get into i do not know
this is all fake i don't know any of
this i although i played the [ __ ] out of
all of these video games specifically uh
mega man contra and tech mobile
but um oh [ __ ] now there's [ __ ] [ __ ]
all over this [ __ ] look look at the
[ __ ] mic everybody if you're watching
on youtube this goddamn [ __ ] ah there's
stuff everywhere
this is i'm too [ __ ] hot
god damn it
hold on rain all the time you know what
be nice is that i got a nice cool glass
of
dramatic
dramana
uh i don't know any of these people
doodsy has gone ahead and written this
diary from 1987 that i had nothing to do
with and here we are and i'm losing my
[ __ ] trying to get everything together
i'm gonna have to get new covers for the
[ __ ] there's black makeup all over the
[ __ ] uh computer and there's white
makeup all over this great second is
sept [ __ ]
september 8th 1987 dear diary my little
brothers i don't have little brothers
i don't have little brothers
okay my all right i have two older
siblings and this is my little brother's
pissed in the bed again last night at
least it's what i told my [ __ ] mom
and dad but it was really me
i snuck into the room and sprayed them
down while they were asleep
piss blaming never gets old
nothing gets my engine going like the
looks on my brother's faces when my mom
tells them they don't get fruit roll-ups
in their lunches as punishment for
pissing the bed
i love pla piss blaming i'm a [ __ ]
piss blamer that's just who i am
so my wife will have to be okay with me
piss blaming her every once in a while
she'll know she didn't piss the bet
obviously she'll know it was me and i
and i'm just pissed blaming but she's
gonna have to pretend
did you ever piss bully no i don't that
piss blaming is a new concept
uh
all right also i didn't have
kid brother september 17 1987. dear
diary my youngest brother cornelius came
in my bedroom last night crying
said he had a bad [ __ ] dream and
asked to sleep in bed with me so i asked
him what it was about i was like corn
what was that [ __ ] dream about buddy
and he said freddy krueger was trying to
get him now i saw a nightmare on elm
street i [ __ ] get it krueger is
pretty [ __ ] scary so i let him sleep
with me
then i pissed my own [ __ ] bed and i
blamed it on him the next morning i'm a
piss blamer oh hell yeah he should have
known better
that's pretty good yeah and you don't
have a brother or anybody in your family
named cornelius uh no we don't have any
i come from an italian family it's odd
enough that my name is william i got the
canadian name hold on let me get some
water
i've never needed this water more
[ __ ] it i'm taking this lid off because
i can't because i got a little sippy
straw ah for [ __ ] sake this is a
[ __ ] disaster dude
no you're this this is exactly how the
crow would drink from a gallon bottle of
water
september 23rd 1987. dear diary piss
blaming his heart
damn it
september 23rd 1987. dear diary piss
blaming is harder to do
to [ __ ] do at school
believe me i've tried but you gotta find
the perfect place to piss so that you
know a teacher will find it and then you
gotta have another person there so you
can blame them and you still gotta be
there to do the blaming without getting
caught
it's just not practical
so i [ __ ] mixed it up today did my
first [ __ ] blame and let me tell you
i loved it
i was in the library took a copy of
taylor two cities off the shelf opened
that [ __ ] first page dropped a
perfectly tapered double twister right
across it
it was the best of times for me and it
was the worst of times for rachel
crustation because i successfully
convinced the librarian that she was the
[ __ ] culprit
i still love piss blame and don't get me
wrong but i don't know if i can be
satisfied with piss blaming by itself
anymore
high class problems i guess
poor rachel crestation so you took his
[ __ ] on a tale of two cities and blamed
it on rachel crustation successfully
nope i didn't chad
this [ __ ] ai said that i did in my
[ __ ] diary that doesn't exist
please tell a friend then break a
preview
if you like dudes here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then